[Applause]
[Music]
on friday 28th of June 2019 it was
announced that the European Commission
had reached an agreement with Mercosur
to create the largest free trade
agreement in its history and folks the
euphoria felt on the other side of the
Atlantic it was not mild domination
director eco it is el acuerdo mas
importante midoriya physique mo a fickle
a conditional trabajar Cantina it has
taken 20 long years to reach an
agreement that affects a population of
almost 800 million people in the quarter
of the world's GDP the agreement reached
will launch a free trade agreements of
the so-called new generation which means
it will deal both with the commerce and
several other issues related to public
regulations however having reached an
agreement does not mean that everything
is solved actually troubles have only
just started for example last September
the 19th the Austrian Parliament voted
against this deal forcing the Austrian
government to veto it at the European
Council Austria could indeed be just the
first out of a bunch of countries that
may oppose the agreement if it was
negotiated why does the Austrian
Parliament want to veto this what are
the advantages and the risks of this
free trade agreement between the
European Union and Mercosur and how
would this deal impacts Latin America so
dear viewers we're going to answer these
questions but first well we need to know
exactly what Merck's or is in the role
it's played since it was founded and
indeed has Marisol been a success or a
bit of a failed experiment
[Music]
Common Market for America
the Latin American history of regional
integration processes is as long as it
is erratic we have to go a long way back
in time at least to the 1950s to find
the first of Latin America's attempts to
unite economically and commercially in
other words to create something similar
to a common market in which they can buy
sell invest or move without national
borders being an obstacle then I can
tell you that 60 years later it still
has the same debates and the same
objectives so you could imagine
something and that's that things didn't
really go according to plan
[Music]
the Montevideo treaty was signed in
February of 1960 creating the a
latin-american free trade association
its most ambitious bet it was made up of
the ten South American Republic's and
Mexico and had a very clear mission to
eliminate all tariffs and most regional
trade obstacles within a maximum period
of ten years
unfortunately that goal was never
reached
however folks what a Latin America's
economic integration process progressed
slower than an arthritic turtle the rest
of the world
it didn't standstill during the 70s 80s
and 90s the European integration project
continued to grow the foundations of the
future NAFTA the free trade agreement
between Canada the United States and
Mexico were set in place during the late
1980s for a president accused of not
getting out two big artillery in support
of the North American trade agreement
how about this down the hall to the
White House East Room he came was three
of his predecessors in Coe and in that
same period Asian countries decided to
take the market by the throat in general
during the 70s 80s and 90s the entire
world took huge strides towards the idea
of boosting international trade
something later known as globalization
even the so-called Uruguay rounds kicked
off in 1986 which would end up paving
the way for the World Trade Organization
yes it may have been that international
frenzy along with a latin-american
economic crises that finally encouraged
the governments of Brazil Argentina
Uruguay and Paraguay to signed the
Treaty of Accession
on March 4 26 1991 the treaty that
established the southern common market
Marcus or Canseco America loca moon
Organo superior encargado de la
conducción política but just a minor
because it's all very well to have great
intentions but getting results is a
different matter almost three decades
later despite its name the southern
common market murca saw hasn't managed
to become a common market and that's not
even its worst problem nor its only one
so listen up he disowned the proper
courtship on periscope and I'm a entire
domain pusher Mercosur the wannabe let's
do an exercise look at the information
and what are we finds well on paper maca
saw is a huge economic zone we're
talking about an organization that
effects almost 13 million square
kilometers almost 300 million
inhabitants in more than three-quarters
of all South America's GDP that's almost
three trillion dollars as you can see
Marcos law had all the elements for
becoming one of the largest markets on
the planet however over time if they've
proven anything it's been their
limitations
and this has a lot to do with the
spirits in which the economic
integration movements in Latin America
were born allow me to explain since the
very first plans were put on the table
they were based on what has been known
as closed regionalism that is
eliminating trade tariffs or countries
within the block while maintaining and
even increasing tariffs towards the rest
of the world in the case of Marcos all
this was done through the so called
common external tariff a common tariffs
applied to imports originating outside
Mercosur with its they intended to favor
intra-regional trade by making imports
from outside the bloc more expensive
through high tariffs of 15 20 or even 30
percent
of course that obviously had
consequences
let me explain yes that barrier might
help some local producers such as
Argentine wheat producers but in general
all those restrictions they stopped
international investment made buying
technology much more expensive and
prevented Marcos or countries from
joining international production chains
and although many politicians don't
realize this that's how the world works
each part of a products is simply made
in a different place therefore if you
prevent or punish the arrival of
supplies that manufacturers need with
tariffs then well you get left out but
it doesn't in there in the end of course
if you defends protectionism against the
rest of the world's what's to stop you
doing it to your own neighbors and
that's precisely what happens with
Marcos or they have been unable to
create a true common market because in
the end neither the various governments
of Brazil nor the different Argentine
governments have ever believed in
international trade as a tool to grow
this has caused a situation in which
unlike the European Union customs
between the Mercs or member countries
themselves have not disappeared
Argentina and Uruguay are members of
Mercosur in theory internal borders
should not exist in America sewers and
practice customs sanitation inspections
and other paperwork mean that the trucks
are delayed for up to 24 hours
Oscar terzaghi to the economist once
another example well here's a question
let me see if you get it right China is
the country to which Argentina applies
these strictest anti-dumping measures as
a way to hinder imports any guess the
second country to which Argentina
applies the most anti-dumping measures 3
to 1 well you might be surprised that
the answer is none other than Brazil yes
you heard that correctly with friends
like these who needs enemies the fact is
that trade doesn't depend on tariffs
alone not at all in fact Latin America
in general has very few regional trade
tariffs but well trade restrictions they
can go much further than that
anti-dumping rights automatically
demanding and not granting import
licenses exchange rate interventions
rules of origin etc etc
[Music]
at the end of the day governments have a
lot of room to maneuver when there isn't
a real common market in the ends between
one thing in another the political
leaders of murka saw have managed to
make this one of the least integrated
commercial areas on the planet you have
to look hard to find another trade
agreement with as little intro zone
growth as médicos or D'Adamo Tolosa
executive director of the Uruguayan
think-tank Center for Economic and
Social Policy Research more than an
internal free trade area macro sewer is
a free domestic protectionism area
Argentina has applied as many
protectionist measures as it could
against the other members in Brazil
didn't help much either
Roberto Chi civil
in fact check out our Argentina's
exports to Brazil have evolved over
recent years
[Music]
however folks all this seems to be
finally changing and that's exactly
where the agreement with the European
Union comes in column of India news
pero laura mercier momento tiempo para
encontrar most mucho leaders complain
about that pattern for money to never
lead us towards a numerical sewer makisu
was born lame beyond the great political
speeches the truth is that it never
really had much hope of achieving
widespread integration but despite
everything the first years they weren't
that not at all in fact the volume of
trade between Marcus or countries x 3
from 8% of all trade in 1991 to 25% in
1998 everything indicated that despite
their limitations things could go
reasonably well however after the year
2000 everything got rather complicated
the new Latin American political leaders
and nestor kirchner
lula da silva and de barra Vasquez
changed Murchison's economic idea
fundamentally turning it into a
political body they even created a
parliament at the max or Parliament
basically at this time of closed
regionalism they moved on to what
leftist theorists themselves have called
post hegemonic regionalism what isn't
very clear is what this means it was
precisely at this time that Argentina
Brazil and Uruguay welcomed Venezuela
into Mercs all through Hugo Chavez and
began the process of integrating Bolivia
although it is true that Venezuela was
indefinitely suspended in 2017 the
problem with all this is that time when
murca saw hasn't yet achieved economic
integration well the economy was hit so
hard that an organization called
southern market became almost everything
except an integrated market
that's how the 25% of trade wait between
Murchison members in 1998 fell to just
over 13 percent in 2017 to give you a
better idea in the European Union this
number amounts to 64% five times more
but now with the arrival of new leaders
like Boston ro and Macri the bloc's
seemed to have changed course the first
great achievement of this new strategy
has been the agreement with the European
Union by signing one of the largest free
trade agreements ever we're talking
about the involvement of 32 countries
almost 800 million people and 19
trillion dollars of GDP and folks this
opens the region up to huge
opportunities especially if Marcus or
countries
a historical opportunity
[Music]
we still don't know all the details nor
whether the agreements will be
immediately applied but once already on
the table sounds very very good see
according to the agreement reached the
European Union will eliminate tariffs
for 92% of Murchison's exports and he'll
also grant access to preferential
conditions to an extra 7.5 percent this
means that less than 1% of the products
that murca sauce sells to the European
Union will be left out of the agreements
meant obviously this will greatly boost
the competitiveness of South American
companies and watch out because the
European Union is a commercial Colossus
that devours products from all over the
world you is a huge market with 500
million inhabitants that represents 20%
of the world economy
it's the biggest investor with a stock
that exceeds 30 percent of global
investments and imports 17 percent of
all the world's purchases of goods and
services from an Argentine government
report
each year the European Union spends more
than two billion dollars on all kinds of
products from the rest of the world well
of this entire amount a little more than
two percent comes from the South
American block each year the European
Union imports more from South Korea than
from all of the Mercosur countries put
together however now this agreement
gives Brazil Argentina Uruguay and
Paraguay the chance to get a bigger and
bigger slice of the pie think about what
this means for example for agriculture
the sector that exports the most Europe
with this Agreement ninety nine percent
of its exports to the EU will be
liberalized and even more than 80
percent will be free of any tariff and
don't forget the Europe imports more
than a hundred and twenty billion
dollars in agri-food products every year
we're talking about huge business here
on the other hands ninety-one percent of
European Union exports to Mercker saw
will also be duty-free this means that
for example Brazilian Argentine
Uruguayan and Paragon companies will be
able to access German technology and
machines with greater ease and better
terms of course the agreement won't be
fully implemented for 15 years though
until then we'll see a progressive
application with the idea of giving the
South American countries x you implement
the reforms that they need in order to
be able to compete this is especially
critical in Argentina's case
[Music]
that's why the bulk of European exports
will be completely liberalized within 10
to 15 years that is Marcus or will
benefit from this agreement much earlier
than most European companies
[Applause]
[Music]
in fact once the agreement is enforced
76% of Murchison's exports will be
duty-free compared to only 13% of
European exports and Argentinian
politicians still complain it's pretty
incredible atado yo Sierra una cuerda
que cela moody physique mo fek la
condición el trabajo in Argentina
of course there's very important point
that we should stress here a free trade
agreements is an opportunity but it's
also a risk if countries decide not to
compete free-trade demands competition
there are no excuses because the
agreement will also establish its own
methodology that is as long as the
agreement is enforced governments cannot
boycott trading with foreign companies
or at least they'll be much more limited
in doing so and everything doesn't end
with the EU now Marisol wants to make
similar agreements with Korea Singapore
Canada after countries and even the
United States and of course doing what
they should have done in the first place
also improves the economic integration
of their own member countries so will we
soon see a true common South American
markets and is Marisol finally taking
off and the most important question will
this agreement between Murchison's the
European Union be able to make Austria
and other hesitant EU member states come
together well only time will tell so I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provide the vocals in this episode
that were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you next time
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]